anderton park primary is the latest
school in birmingham to face
protests calling for teaching about gay
relationships to be stopped
our childrens are innocent the early age
and we just don't want them to be
the mind to be corrupted argument is not
that
don't teach them is that why you
teaching them at this age being muslim
and being homosexual unfortunately
doesn't coincide want to
together but the muslim community in the
school is saying
that aside we do not discriminate
against the lgbt community
the head teacher says the education
secretary needs to take action
you almost need to sit in a school like
ours and listen to what's being said
and the unpleasantness that it causes
and the homophobic nature of some of the
things that are said
we've had so many emails from all over
the country had teachers
in croydon manchester uh saying this is
happening to me
in my school and this should not be the
case so yes i am calling
on the secretary of state to uh to come
out very clearly
she likens what's happening to the
so-called trojan horse scandal
in 2014 ofsted found evidence of an
organised campaign in birmingham to
impose
faith-based ideology in secular schools
kind of hand slapping on the table i
demand that you will not teach children
it's all right to have two moms
that kind of those kind of behaviors are
very
very similar if not identical to what
happened
five six seven years ago in trojan horse
times the school says the way
homosexuality
is discussed particularly with little
children is using storybooks so this one
is about a baby penguin with two dads
and this story king and king follows a
prince
who falls in love with another prince
this is an aggressive
indoctrination demonstrations at
parkfield community school have forced
teachers there to stop the lessons
despite ofstead saying they are age
appropriate
lee trust that runs this and four other
schools have also suspended the classes
the protests are causing concern for gay
muslims in this community
hearing them right now it's quite
heartbreaking because
we the muslim community right now what
they're doing is alienating themselves
from the rest of the community again the
department for education
say they want children to know there are
many types of relationships
and trust head teachers to decide what's
appropriate for children
becky johnson sky news birmingham